The newest actor to step into the Spidey suit,
Tom Holland made his Marvel Cinematic Universe
debut in 2016's Captain America: Civil War,
then basked in the solo spotlight for his
own film, Spider-Man: Homecoming, a year later.
Holland has since burst into the mainstream,
established himself as a (still quite young)
A-list actor, and proven his iteration of
Spider-Man to be an integral part of the MCU,
including 2018's Avengers: Infinity War.
Despite his Marvel movie experience, however,
Holland had trouble keeping it together on
the Infinity War set, finding it difficult
to work with a fellow actor.
Speaking with Hey U Guys, Holland revealed
that he actually had trouble acting opposite
Chris Pratt, known in the MCU for his Guardians
of the Galaxy franchise character:
"Star Lord."
"Who?"
"Star Lord, man.
Legendary outlaw."
But don't worry about prima donna drama on
the set of Infinity War, the reason for Holland's
strife is actually pretty darn adorable.
Speaking of Pratt, Holland said:
"He is so funny, he's so fun, and he has such
great stories about his career and about the
industry, and he's also just super talented."
But it wasn't being in awe of Pratt's sheer
talent that gave Holland trouble.
Pratt was simply too funny, and Holland couldn't
be around him without folding over in a fit
of laughter.
"I found it quite difficult because he would
make me laugh so much.
You know?
He's the man.
I absolutely love him."
Not that anyone ever doubted it, but it seems
the Guardians actor is just as goofy and fun-loving
when the cameras stop rolling as Marvel fans
would hope.
We can imagine that with Chris Pratt being
Chris Pratt, it must have been hard for Holland
to keep a straight face.
Admittedly, though, a 15-year-old kid like
Peter Parker would probably be tickled pink
in the presence of the silly Star-Lord, so
perhaps some of Holland's smirks that make
it into the film's theatrical cut are completely
genuine.
"He's the new blood, get used to it."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!